it's time for superlatives on this uh
monday
and christmas
where the love is flowing
i'll let you go first although i
actually i actually spent time the game
last night was sufficiently
unexciting
in the fourth quarter that i was able to
spend time putting some ideas together
for today's superlatives so i'm ready to
go what do you got all right well i mean
uh i've seen this movie before
uh i think i gotta go down to um
uh maybe i shouldn't use that maybe i
should go who's your daddy award to tom
brady because like he's the falcons
daddy i think i like that better who's
your daddy uh you know who
who's your daddy uh it's tommy tommy
brady that's your daddy atlanta for what
he did i mean again down in this down to
start the second half atlanta falcons
brings them back i mean brady i thought
i know that was the best half of
football he's played in tampa bay it's
tampa bay is another one of those teams
a little like kansas city you get
frustrated because you see the potential
and how good they are and i'm still not
so sure they're not one of the most
complete teams in the nfc when you see
halves of football like that but man
you know i know the world thinks i'm i'm
a tom brady hater cause i don't say he's
the greatest quarterback of all time but
holy crap the way he's throwing the
football right now at his age i mean it
is special
it was laser beams around the field
yesterday and i i just i can't say
enough about that but just the way he
looked the way the offense looked and
just how they accelerated in the second
half oh 17 nothing hey 17-7 it was 24-7
and they just never stopped and they
just kept answering the belly answering
the bell and their defense settled in
and they really were unstoppable but
brady in the second half as good as i've
seen them in a few years really
yeah and look they've done this
throughout the course of the season i i
chronicled every time they fell behind
early double digits 17 points they were
down 17 of the chargers in the first
half they've been down sometimes they
come back sometimes they don't that's
not going to work for the buccaneers in
the postseason they can't count on that
the packers for example down 10 nothing
they were before finally waking up they
can't let it go as long as they did
although it makes for an exciting second
half which we saw yesterday first one
for me and i've got several that i like
today this is the great work if you can
get it award and
i heard from
many raiders fans last week who
vehemently and strenuously objected to
my position that john gruden
is getting a free pass with the raiders
and if it was any other coach he'd be at
least be on the discussion of being on
the hot seat
and one raiders fan very keenly pointed
out i have no problem with you
making that argument as to gruden
because you're right but also at some
point somebody's got to say something
about john elway and that's why i call
it the great work if you can get it
award because he has fallen into a spot
where he's never going to be fired until
there is an owner appointed by the three
trustees who are managing the team until
they decide which of the seven bowling
children is going to win this bizarre
willy wonka contest and become the owner
of the franchise and that may not work
they may have to sell the team in fact
that's the way the wind is blowing until
all that happens whenever it may happen
john elway is not going anywhere because
those trustees have enough to worry
about without having to hire a new gm
and who in their right mind is going to
take that job when they know what's
coming you've got no job security
because at any moment it can all blow up
and they sell the team and then the
first order of businesses you get fired
so
oh and and
look i got a ton of respect for the fact
that they won super bowl 50.
but
my my
my roller coaster has been when he was
hired in 2011 i think what are the
broncos doing nobody's even talking
about hiring john elway for any job in
any front office and you're putting him
in charge of your football operation are
you kidding me and then of course they
win the super bowl and i had to eat crow
well now i have to uneat the crow
because here they are and it's
it's punctuated by the fact that they
passed on josh allen chris
that's the thing that really brought it
into focus right they passed on josh
allen i know they got bradley chubb but
franchise quarterback pass rusher
there's still there's still a stat you
want the franchise quarterback no doubt
obviously no doubt they passed on josh
allen and they got to see firsthand what
they passed on and that just really
underscores the fact and and look hall
of fame talent john elway put a super
bowl winning team together but other
than having payton manning fall into his
lap
what's he done by way of finding a
quarterback and to pass on josh allen in
a year where case keenum was your
starter it's not like you could say well
we were set at the position no you
weren't you weren't case keenum was a
placeholder so uh if
i'm a broncos fan right now and i've
endured four straight losing seasons i
would be up in arms about this and i
would feel helpless because none of it
is going to change until there's an
owner of that team and nobody knows when
that's going to be well i mean listen
there's a lot first off i would like to
wax poetically about your point with
josh allen because josh allen is you
know i i put out a tweet as i was
sitting there watching the game on
sunday and i said i just i asked you
know
is is josh allen officially in the
stratosphere with rogers and mahomes
listen i know he's not aaron rodgers or
patrick mahomes yet but i think for like
2020 football and what we've seen
through week 15
i mean i don't think it's crazy to think
he's in that conversation with the way
that he's playing and the way that that
team is playing you know i mean i don't
know do you do you think that's crazy
mike to say that right now you know i
understand in totality he's not in
rogers and mahomes class yet i get that
but for this season in moments where you
go hey if i need a quarterback to put
the offense on my shoulders and make
plays and do that i think he's at least
in the conversation i mean at least i
think you got to give him the respect to
that what he did there the other game
the other day at night on saturday you
know that was special again we just saw
that denver defense not let mahomes and
the chiefs in the end zone like six
different times in the red zone and then
there was josh allen and i know the
broncos weren't at full strength but he
was scoring touchdowns every time he was
down there i'm trying to say he's better
than my homes or the chiefs or anything
i'm just trying to say it's damn special
and you're right elway blewed on that
one okay for sure you know he's had some
questionable quarterback decisions
there's no doubt and things have not
been good as of late there in denver i
you can't argue that and yeah maybe he
is at a spot here because of ownership
where he's getting a little bit of a a
free passport oh maybe it's not yeah
there's no one in place to fire him
there's no one in place you're right but
they're not going to well but but he's
getting towards the hot seat
conversation i think it's who's going to
fire him i don't know he's going to fire
him the trustees are going to fire him
and then who are they going to hire
that's my point who are you going to
hire i don't know of a team that's about
to get sold but we're not there i don't
know you're right it might not happen
yet i don't know we can't fault john
elway and then you can't start keep
saying that that's why i said it's good
work if you can get it well you can't
fault this is the other thing i don't
like what you say though you can't say
peyton manning fell into his lap
everybody wanted peyton manning elway
had built an amazing team that peyton
manning went i want to go there because
even if i'm bad in the worst quarterback
in football i think we can win a super
bowl so
he there's not a lot of teams that have
had first and second you know first and
second seeds in the playoffs and been to
the super bowl twice in the last eight
nine years broncos are one of them in
fact i think it's only them in seattle
so he did get a little free pass because
of that history too i think
i think i think the
the franchise quarterback hall of fame
club helped him speak a language to
peyton manning that got manning to sign
on
right and there were some rough spots
there were some rough spots definitely
between a couple of alpha males who were
trying to run the team and uh but but it
all worked out in the end they got their
super bowl as peyton manning walked off
into the sunset and the fumes of that
may be keeping
but again nobody's in place to fire john
elway they would they would be in much
worse shape if they had to scramble to
go hire a general manager for what may
be the final years of this group before
they face the reality they are gonna
have to sell the team and that reality
is coming closer and closer and if i'm a
broncos fan i just want it to happen
let's move on let's get on with it and
let's start building toward a brighter
future all right chris what do you have
next well i think my next one i'm gonna
go to the uh we haven't talked about
this game the the boomer sooner award
you know i don't like oklahoma they
tortured me in college but damn those
two quarterbacks yesterday and that
boomer sooner matchup was fun to watch
with the eagles versus the arizona
cardinals it really was you know first
off i think what i've come to the
realization is that the eagles are going
to be trading carson wentz this off
season the way it looks that's going to
happen i mean jalen hurts you know as
much as i questioned his ability to
throw and be consistent that way coming
out in the nfl draft you know his
running is more special than maybe i
gave it credit for and something we talk
about with tony dungy a lot when you can
run that way
it simplifies defenses to where maybe
the fact that you're not a top-tier
thrower yet
it still can be overcome because you're
getting great looks because they're
worried about your defense and if you're
open he's gonna hit you i mean he makes
plays takes care of the football he's
like the opposite carson wentz is this
year so between him that was awesome for
jalen hurts even though they lost and
then hey arizona they got back on track
on the offensive side of the ball kyler
murray's arm looked as live as i've seen
it look uh over the last few weeks you
know and then making playmaking ability
and just getting the ball in the deandre
hopkins hands again who's kind of
disappeared in that offense you know it
was a fun game to watch but it was fun
to see arizona's offense kind of get
jump started again and see if they can
make a little run here down the stretch
well and and look the the point we made
last week calamari had been about four
weeks removed from injuring that
shoulder against the seahawks so he was
getting to the point where we should
expect him to be healthy he's playing
through it it is going to get better on
the fly and it did
and that whole carson wentz angle kind
of a strange book end of sunday splash
yeah right
last week he reports the eagles are
going to keep him this week he reports
that he once wants out clearly the first
report came from the eagles who were
trying to maximize trade leverage and
step one in maximizing trade leverage is
saying we ain't trading the guy yeah
yesterday's report clearly came from
wentz's camp they're trying to keep the
eagles from playing a game with wentz
and if you are going to be traded you
want to be traded for less you don't
want your team to give up a herschel
walker ransom right to get you then it
makes it harder for you to be
competitive there and there was a report
last night contradicting schefter's
report this came from the aap rob mottie
who covers the eagles and the end works
for the ap and has a lot of equal
stories he said
wentz doesn't want out and that once
hasn't told anyone that well here's how
you harmonize it
wence hasn't said anything but his
agents have that's how that's how it
happens wentz is trying to exert
leverage over the situation he doesn't
want to languish on the bench in
philadelphia if jalen hurts is the guy
and he doesn't want the eagles playing
games with him like they tried to play
the game with nick falls well we're
going to use the franchise tag and then
try to trade him until they realize they
couldn't trade him so then they just let
him walk away wence wants to be sure
that he gets a full and fair chance to
go where he wants to go this is part of
that effort to apply pressure to the
eagles to make sure he gets what he
wants agreed i mean i think wence needs
to go all in on that you know if i'm
advising carson wentz that's what i
would tell him to do you don't want to
be there anymore just make it be known
lower your trade value that's not their
fault they drafted a quarterback in the
second round it's not your fault i mean
carson wentz it's not your fault they
drafted a guy in the second round tough
so i would start doing that right now
because you're right you know you don't
as a player you know you don't want the
team that's going to trade for you like
you said to give up a big part of their
football team to get you the other thing
too you know it takes a lot of teams out
of the trade market when the when the
asking price is so high you know by
lowering your price you get you bring in
a lot of teams that you know maybe
didn't have the assets or want to do it
so if i'm carson wentz i go full-blown i
went out of philadelphia blow this up
he's in a no-win situation anyways
carson wentz his agent if you're
listening you're in a no-win situation
philadelphia the city doesn't want you
anymore i'm sorry it's screwed up but
they don't and it's gonna take him to be
like an mvp three years in a row for
them to finally go oh yeah he is a good
quarterback so if i'm him i want out of
there and he should make it happen the
only risk in taking that position is
that your next team
may be leery that they're that's right
going to be on the wrong end of that but
you know what to get back to the point
from the top of the segment it didn't
stop the seahawks from giving up two
first-round picks plus to get jamal
adams knowing full well that at some
point jamal adams could turn
that same ire that we saw directed to
the jets toward the seahawks but that's
what
a next carson wentz team would at least
have to worry about a little bit unless
they fully understand the way we do that
this is just his way of trying to get to
a new situation without that new team
having give up a lot if anything the new
team should be thankful that he's doing
it because it's reducing potentially the
price they're gonna have to pay to get
him next one for me the deja vu all over
again award goes to the texans and the
cults think about where the cults would
be right now if they didn't have some
weird fluky dumb thing happen as the
texans were driving to win or tie twice
in the last three games it was 26 20 a
couple of weeks ago there's that weird
shotgun snap when do you ever see a
weird shotgun snap in the nfl you never
see it nick martin had a weird shotgun
snap and that killed the chance of the
texans to beat the colts and then
yesterday the texans down seven 27-20
not 26-20 driving and there's a fumble
into the end zone and that's that for
the houston texans and you flip those
games you just take one of those games
away and all of a sudden the cults are
in a lot more tenuous position in the
afc you take both of them away and
they're on the outside looking in and it
just shows you that even when a team is
good there can be you can just focus in
on this or this or that or that and it's
like boy if that didn't go your way yeah
you're done and and that's the thing
about the nf
there are so many
little fluky bounces of an oblong ball
that will determine whether you're
10 and six
or
eight and eight
and if you're eight and eight you ain't
getting in and if you're 10 and six you
are and uh it's it's just crazy it's
maddening and all the effort all the
time all the sweat all the planning all
the hours
of work by the coaches and all the time
spent working out
as a team's fate can so often come down
to a bad call a bounce of the ball and
you're either in or you're out based on
that no it is it's heartbreaking it
really is and it's like to me it you
know again the cults are doing a lot of
good things definitely
the the thing that jumps out to me about
that game more than anything is you know
d sean watson he's so freaking awesome i
mean he's really he's the reason they're
in the game he's the reason they got a
chance it's the it's he's the ultimate
reason why you can't give wins and
losses always and blame it on the
quarterback with losses you can't do any
more than deshaun watson did to win that
game yesterday i mean it's really it's
he's plays at such a high level his
ability to avoid the pass rush and make
big throws all game long
is just remarkable that way and yeah the
the colts are very fortunate that they
escaped with a win there uh that was big
for them with everybody else winning the
afc
um
my next one is the um it happened mike
it happened
it happened do you know what i'm talking
about it happened it happened it
what um he won't be back he's dead
he went into the lava and he is dead now
the terminator's dead it's official it
took 20 years but damn somebody in the
afc's finally shot the damn terminator i
don't know what they found or what kind
of weapon it was oh that's right they
got tom brady out of there uh either way
you know
that game yesterday new england patriots
you know offensive struggles as usual
playing through their defense doing all
that but really the star the star of the
show is is miami and what brian flores
has done there with that football team
their defense they're they're one of the
better defenses in football they make
plays every week and then they just mash
the patriots in the run game you know i
give them a lot of credit the patriots
tried to play the old
hey we're going to put a lot of people
at the line of scrimmage you don't want
to run into all these people you want to
throw the ball with tua here and brian
flores and chan gailey i give them the
credit they didn't bite they didn't take
the bait they said no we're we still
don't think you can stop the run even
though you got a lot of guys there we're
gonna still run it and they ran it and
ran it for success and uh big win for
them i mean just the attitude of the
dolphins the toughness they play tua
again not spectacular but makes plays
and knows how to manage the football
game and uh is a big win for the
dolphins and brian flores you know this
may be a multi-year thing for the
patriots too they've got tua in miami
they've got josh allen in buffalo yeah
they may have trevor lawrence still with
the jets we were talking about this last
night do the patriots lay down week 17
for the jets to ensure that trevor
lawrence goes to jacksonville coach
dungey
actually seemed to endorse the idea of
putting jared stidham in the game
putting some backup offensive linemen in
the game evaluating some young players
and just letting nature take its course
and if you lose to the jets you lose to
the jets and you don't have to deal with
trevor lawrence for the next 10 years
yeah it's it's an interesting thought i
mean it really is um
i don't see new england being that way
as far as like packing it in but they
might have that week 17 hey let's see
what a few of these guys got
you know a little extra film to evaluate
you know and and and maybe it does set
up that way you know just conveniently
for them uh who knows it's gonna be
interesting it really is and i don't
know hey i was gonna say that when we
were talking about that game before just
why we're on it real quick like did sam
darnold was that a good thing for him
that they won yesterday did that keep
him in new york maybe he should have
thrown a late pick and been like i don't
want to be here next year i want you
guys to take trevor lawrence i want out
of this place
well the worst case scenario for him is
to still be there under the fourth year
of his guaranteed contract
and
not be the starter or at least be the
placeholder until
justin fields or trevor lawrence take
over because you've already got the
money fully guaranteed if you don't find
a trade partner you just keep him so i
look the jets players
wanted to avoid
they wanted to avoid desperately going
0-16 you don't want that on your resume
jets fans were happy to trade owen 16.
for trevor lawrence that's a great yeah
it's a great cover there
that's a great cover but you know what a
lot of people were asking on twitter
what does it mean because they don't
know who lawrence welk is the grinch's
stole trevor
yeah but hey
it's i i still think the players the
coaches definitely the coaches adam gase
doesn't want owen 16 on his resume the
players don't want to be associated
with 16. even though the browns have
done it and the lions have done it you
don't want to be what would have been
the last 0-6 team assuming the nfl goes
to 17 games next season all right i got
one more real quick one and this goes
back to our top story of the day the
chiefs beating the saints last week when
you were home
before we had technical difficulties
that knocked you off do you remember
that you have happy thoughts about that
i don't know
i said you look like things and you look
like you look like mr freeze i said you
look like mr freeze because you had that
blue yeah you look like schwarzenegger
in the batman movie right the mr freeze
award
i've got to give it to patrick mahomes
we have to pray
revolutionary what this guy does with
the football in his hands because there
were two moments yesterday that i
noticed and of course we're getting
ready for a show i'm on the phone i'm
getting dressed we're rehearsing there
may have been more but there were two
that i saw that blew me away there was a
moment where he was running around
behind the line of scrimmage avoiding
potential guys that would sack him
and he did this move where cam jordan
just
froze i mean it is like patrick mahomes
has some sort of gun that he points at
and he presses the button and you freeze
cam jordan did not know what to do and
it was awesome and the throw on the back
end eclipsed that inst it was just that
quick little moment in time but it was
incredible what he did to cam jordan i
mean cam jordan's one of the best
passwords
that was the one where he threw it that
he hit sammy watkins on the big
completion down the field or yes yes
okay yeah yeah yeah that was amazing and
then there was a and then there was
another one
where
and this is just sandlot backyard stuff
he's he's he sees the opening he runs to
the line of scrimmage
and he knows he's going to keep running
and there's a guy 10 yards down field
and and even though mahomes was past the
line of scrimmage when he did it he did
a quick pump he turned and i got acted
yeah i know and the guy jumped straight
up in the air now he didn't freeze right
but he jumps straight up in the air so
you don't have to worry about that guy
making the tackle mahomes just keeps
going it is just amazing to see what he
can do instinctively and that's where
the playbook ends the game plan ends the
scripted plays end and it's just put a
guy out there who has an uncanny skill
set that this game hasn't seen and it's
a level of domination that you only see
on a schoolyard and we all have memories
of that the one kid that no one could
catch the one kid that could run circles
around everyone and drive you crazy
that's my homes you don't see that
at the highest level of football when
you do it's rare and i mean not since
michael vick and for vic it was just
straight ahead speed with mahomes
there's just this
kind of strange elusive he's like he's
not the fastest guy yeah but he the way
he moves it almost like puts people into
a trance and they think they have a beat
on him and then they don't that's what
makes that 30 yard sack last week even
more stunning because he just knows he
knows
where they opening is he knows how just
how to how to hypnotize someone just in
that instant to get by i mean it was
it's it's it's unbelievable it really is
and we need to appreciate it because
it's not going to last forever and
hopefully there'll be more kids like him
in the pipeline no no i i well i think
they're you know
like him i don't know but you're right i
mean the game's going that way and i
think quarterbacks are more and more you
know doing that stuff i'm even like i've
told you before seeing kids doing it in
flag football who are 10 years old my
little boy is running around like that
and doing crap like that now so you know
it's being indoctrinated into a lot of
young kids and and
mike that's why we talked about early on
and it just
it's that ability that i think has given
the the past protection a a free pass
lately where it hasn't been that great
but you know he's fast enough to where
he challenges you to where oh man i
gotta run harder he might turn the
corner on me but then he has great
ability to kind of start and stop and
then you're worried about all the
awkward throws so if you're chasing him
you're going man i gotta run hard to
catch him wait i better get my hands up
because he might throw some sidearm
laser beam right you know right across
my face or by my ear hole and then you
have to worry about him stopping and
spinning out and doing all that stuff
he's just got a lot of versatility in
his moves and he's just got you know
like you said a great natural backyard
feel for what to do how to move and make
the throw that's uh yeah pretty pretty
damn special
and you just don't see it at the nfl
level because they swarm to you the
athletes are so good that you don't get
away with that stuff they come get you
they catch you they hit you and you
don't do it anymore
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports